yo sup guys my name is a channel welcome
to episode 44 of game programming so
yesterday we took a look at all these
different input methods and basically
how our x and y variables how our
location of the player is going to
change based on you know our keyboard
inputs so if we if we run this you'll
see that we actually drew some text on
the screen and that we're able to
actually just the location of our player
and everything works correctly and arts
brilliant but let's go back to mob that
is one way to do it right if we go back
to mob we've already got a way to do it
right we've got this move method so why
don't we actually use that move method
and what I'm gonna do today is it's
going to be quite a short episode but
I'm gonna I want to take a look at in
depth at how this move method actually
works and how we actually use it in our
update method so let's just scrap all
this code all right all I was doing
yesterday was showing you guys how to
transfer to the player today we're going
to simply do move friggin player update
yeah we're going to do it this way we're
going to make two variables called X&Y
they're both going to equal zero and
then all I'm going to do actually
there's going to be X a and y a and what
I want to do is I'm going to say that
you know if I don't know if if we if
input dot up right we'll just add 1 to X
oh sorry Y or subtract 1 from Y actually
there's a complete opposite of what I
was supposed to there let's just cough
it a few times if we a null - why so - y
a fizzer X and right left so all I'm
doing here is I'm setting the correct
sort of bounce I guess and remember
every time it's going to come through
here it's actually going to set them
back to 0 it's going to reset them back
to 0 so doing that way I need order in
your microphone stand I said that last
episode but hey just tightening it again
that should be better maybe all right so
we're doing this again it's going to
reset it but at the end of this we're
going to save it if X a is not equal to
0 so in otherwise if it's it's not equal
to 0 or
or if why a is not equal to zero then
we're going to actually move with X a
and Y all right that's how we're going
to do it so right what's going to happen
is if X a is an equal zero right the
only thing it can equal and I let me
just fix this up before I scroll thing
up the only thing that X a can equal if
it's not zero is negative one or one all
right and we're going to feed that into
the move method now we'll take a look at
this in depth but first of all let's
take a look at if it works and as you
can see it works exactly like it did
before but we're actually using the
correct method for moving our player now
so let's dive into this and take a take
a look at it code line by line so first
things first right these variables so
basically I've created these two
variables right and that there aren't
they only exist for one purpose they
just note down the direction of which
which way the player is supposed to move
right so in other words what's going to
happen here is if if we actually if if
the game detects that our up button and
out remember we actually have two up
buttons assigned we've got W and the up
arrow key if any of them are actually
detected as being pressed it's going to
decrement from Y so basically it's going
to - - just means it is going to take it
down a notch yes it's going to it's
going to actually subtract one unit from
that variable some other words Y it's
kind of equal to zero it will become
negative one okay if input op is
detected and let's just say that the up
arrow is the only thing that player
happens to be holding when we actually
in this cycle right so first thing it
does define the two variables sets in
both equal to zero then it subtracts one
from Y a so now X a is equal to zero and
Y is equal to negative one and since
none of these 'true keeps going and over
here it says that if X a is doesn't
equal to 0 does equal 0 but or if Y a
doesn't equal zero and it equals
negative one which is not zero so this
condition is true it's going to move
with the parameters of what 0 and
negative 1 because y equals negative
one and in the move method is going to
come over here it's going to take down
the direction because Y is less than
zero knows that it knows the direction
is zero this is taking down the
direction and also is going to add
negative one to Y because Y y a is equal
to negative one so it's going to add
negative one to what Y which means that
it will actually go down one so if what
happens to be zero here well let's say
what happens to be 300 Y will become 299
thus it's actually translating the
player so that's how it works line by
line um and it obviously does the same
thing for X and y if they're both for
example if we're holding the a button
and the W button at the same time we
will go diagonally right because W both
negative one and if we plug in plug in
here move we'll pull up the parameters
negative one and negative one and it
will actually be subtracting 1 from X as
well as dragging one from Y at the same
time which of course is completely
completely fine it will just do it at
the same time and that's it guys that is
really how it works
I don't think further explanation is
necessary if you guys have any questions
though drop a comment um remember I do
have a subreddit it's reddit it's our
slash the churner
so I really made that so that you guys
could sort of discuss that thing and
sort of have like a forum up there the
link to the subreddit will be in the
description if you guys have any like
problems if you guys want to ask a
question best place to do it if you
actually want to get answered is there
um because people will actually help you
out as well because I don't have enough
time to help all of you guys out but if
you start a thread there I'm sure you'll
get help like within a few hours so yeah
anyway guys I hope you enjoyed this
episode of game programming if you did
please hit the like button and I'll see
you guys tomorrow later guys
you